hi I'm Matt Carroll with the Senate
Pacific media and also the future of
news initiative and I'm very excited to
be here and when they asked me to give a
talk I wanted to make it sort of a
BuzzFeed Abul kind of thing so I said
okay five minutes five top media leaders
five hot new news trends I figured
that'd be pretty easy
I'll call ten top media leaders I'll get
five and I'm good to go so of course I
call ten and ten called me back totally
screwed up my headline and I'm sure
there is a lesson to be learned there
about writing your headline first and
then your story but I have no idea what
that lesson is so I'm going to totally
ignore it and just move on with my talk
so here are the ten nine people have by
the way the see is circa nine you've
probably haven't heard of and it's
fresco down in the lower right and it
really doesn't belong up here in a lot
of ways this content is very very thin
but what is cool about it is that it is
a very well designed picture news app
and what's even cooler is that it was
designed by two nineteen year old
freshman at NYU and I was very impressed
by that and I thought to myself okay
it's so neat that the tools that exist
today are really good that can allow 19
year olds to create a very creditable
news site and that's really cool but it
also made me think okay if 19 year olds
are doing this
what is the mobile news world gonna look
like in another couple of years when the
seasoned professionals get get through
tearing it apart and putting it back
together and by the way I just love
these these kids attitudes vandal Daniel
Bandemer I'm sure I'm killing his last
name and a guy named John Mayer so I
talked to these ten people the two terms
I kept hearing again and again was
tipping point Mobile is just everywhere
now it has gone from basically nothing
not so long ago to now where it's 50% at
the post The Times BuzzFeed The Guardian
Twitter is at 80% and of course that
doesn't even count places like circa
which are basically just they're they're
designed just for mobile that is atom
man up there in case you don't recognize
them if the one of the things that was
also clear was the the continuing
atomization of news this goes to sites
like circa where they break everything
at the little
bitesize paragraphs as you move along
but it also includes sites like NYT now
or yahoo news digest with a taking a big
bucket of news and putting into a little
tiny bucket or a relatively small bucket
for people and the idea that it's much
easy for people to consume over mobile
this is sort of further down the line
people like Marty Baron talked about
this and David Cone at circa wearables
and it's clearly not here yet it's
definitely on the horizon but the way
they talk about it mobile was on the
horizon not so long ago and it caught up
very very quickly with people so there
that it's something that keeping a sharp
eye on Marty Baron also talked about
just-in-time news in the idea that you
are a consumer your driving past the
drycleaners all of a sudden you get a
ping that says hey by the way you left
some shirts at the dry cleaners maybe
she just swing by and grab them right
now again the emphasis was on mobile
news is in its infancy things are gonna
change pretty radically for users a lot
more contextualized news you're gonna
hear from alexis unfold which is one
thing rap genius is another thing
despite its name it has some really cool
ways if you including context for stuff
Daniel Schultz who's here is also
creating something called truth goggles
which is another way of contextualizing
personalize there's also gonna be much
more participatory and a lot more
personalized news coming up we held a
hackathon here two weeks ago and there
was a lot of work and personalization
one of sort of the neat but very simple
ideas was when someone does a story on
say votes in the legislature a line
would be dropped in the story depending
on where your zip code was telling you
how your local rep voted simple but
effective also things are changing very
very quickly for newsrooms this is I
think a difficult thing for a lot of
people to understand so far and that is
mobile is just a very very different
language and things are changing very
very fast for mobile and it is just
really different experience for people
on whether from desktop to a mobile
experience Marty Baron talked a lot
about this how
you can still do heavy duty
investigative journalism on mobile but
it's gonna be done in a very very
different way
burt Herrmann at Storify talked a lot
about this and everyone has seen this
the mobile designs it's much simpler
much cleaner
bigpictures big headlines fewer
headlines The Guardian recently went to
this sort of design a couple weeks ago
and it kind of brings me back actually
to when I got into newspapers when
modular design was becoming very popular
I know I'm dating myself here but one of
the I guess it's a concern for me is
that that news organizations that are
deep like the Washington Post or The
Guardian they have tons of great stories
and it's difficult to surface these
stories I think with this clean design
it's just something that has people have
to be to deal with as they move forward
Jonah Peretti talked about this a little
bit a minute he's it's being overstated
a little bit my headline has I'm not not
that commodity stories are in jeopardy
so to speak but does it really make
sense they have 30 different people
covering the president speech when all
the 30 stories are going to be exactly
the same on the other hand Jonah and
Marty Baron and and I actually totally
agree with these guys that investigative
reporting is not going away there's been
a lot of stories I think talking about
sort of may disappear because of loss
and resources and stuff but it's just
not going to happen
it just makes too much sense readers
love this stuff it from a business point
of view it makes total sense because it
helps you build your brand and and and
and reporters love doing it to like it's
just it's just gonna keep going and
winners and losers in newsroom losers
would be reporters say the solo
reporters who used to go out there and
just take the notebook come back to the
newsroom and just write and they were
done that is kind of going by the
wayside you have to be much more of a
team player these days work with news
devs
videographers the whole bit it's a team
game now winners and this comes from Dan
singer who is maybe floating around out
here and David Cohen at circa if you are
a talented news dev you are in luck
because you have won the lottery they
are these news sites not desperate for
people like you and witness Erin pill
Hofer probably a lot of people know him
used to be at the New York Times and he
was just snatched up by the Guardian and
they are very very happy to get him and
that's it so
wants to talk about the the slides or
the future news or the Boston Red Sox
glad to chat with you later thank you
very much thank you